نذهب الى مدينه سرمدا شمال ادلب منير
مصطفى نائب مدير الدفاع المدني السوري
مرحبا بك معنا منير في سياق هذه التغطيه
الدفاع المدني كنتم وجهتم مناشدات بايصال
المعدات والمساعدات هل تلقى مناشداتكم
بوصول مساعدات تشمل معدات فرق انقاذ اي
صدى حتى الساعه
حصلت حتى يوم امس شهدنا على قصص وروايات
وكنا نقلناها مباشره على شاشه العربيه
واخرها انقاذ الفتاه بالسبعه سنوات هل
يمكن القول انه في الجانب السوري انتهت
هذه الامل تماما فقط عمليه انتشال جثث لا
اكثر
في الحقيقه يعني انا تحدثت يعني في بعض
البرامج عن هذا الامر طبيعه الابنيه
الموجوده في الشمال السوري تختلف يعني الى
حد كبير عن طبيعه الابنيه وانشائها في
جنوب تركيا الامنيه في جنوب تركيا هي
ابنيه يعني مجهزه لمقاومه الزلازل فتكون
عمليه الانهيار هي عباره عن انهيارات يعني
ميلان او انهيارات ليس بشكل كامل تطبق
الصبات الديوانيه على بعض تخلف ورائها
العديد من مثلثات الحياه كما يعني يعرف
بالمصطلحات رجال الانقاذ تخلف تحتها
مثلثات الحياه هذه الاماكن
الموجوده تحت الانقاذ هي اماكن يعني لا
يكون هناك اصابات لا يكون هناك اي نزيف
لهؤلاء الاشخاص العالقين ضمن هذه المثلثات
ويكون هناك فرصه يعني حتى الست او سبعه
ايام قد يستطيع فرق الانقاذ انتشاله هؤلاء
العالقين في هذه المثلثات وهم على قيد
الحياه في الجانب السوري للاسف الابنيه لم
تكن مجهزه لموضوع الزلازل وهي ابنيه طبعا
حصلت انت تعرفين يعني عشر سنوات من الحرب
مستمره في في سوريا فهذه ابنيه كلها حديثه
وكانت ابنيه طارئه اصلا في زمن الحرب فهذه
الامنيه غير مجهزه لنقاومه الزلازل فهي
اطبقت بالكامل ولا تخلف ورائها مثل هذه
المثلثات والمثلثات التي تواجدت في هذه
الابنيه طبعا استطاع فريق الفوز البيضاء
الوصول اليها وسحب العالقين منها وبالتالي
اعلن انه سينتقل الى مرحله اخرى لانه لم
يبقى هناك اي مثلثات حياه لم يبقى هناك اي
فراغ ضمن هذه الانقاض لم يصل اليه الفريق
الخوذ البيضاء وبالتالي تحولت العمليه الى
انتشال انتشال جثث يعني قلما تحصل هذه
العمليه وهي تكون معجزه ان يكون هناك شخص
لا زال على قيد الحياه في ظل مثل هذه
الانهيارات في شمال غرب سوريا يعني حتى
هذه اللحظه نحن نتكلم عن يوم السابع وهو
وقت طويل يعني حتى ولو لم تكن هناك اصابه
فرس الحياه تكون شبه معدومه في هذا الوقت
يعني هل كلامك يفسر ما يقال عن اننا دائما
نسمع قصص نجاه في تركيا وقليلا ما نسمع عن
قصص نجاه في الشمال السوري خصوصا بعد مرور
الاثنتين وسبعين ساعه
ذهبيتين ودخولنا في اليوم السابع اليوم
نعم في الحقيقه يعني هذا هو التفسير يعني
الاكبر
لعمليه انقاذ يعني عالقين لا زالوا على
قيد الحياه في تركيا في جنوب تركيا وعدم
تواجد هؤلاء الاشخاص منذ اكثر من ثوان
واربعين ساعه لم يكن هناك سحب لاي عالق من
تحت الانقاذ في شمال غرب سوريا وانتقلت
الامور الى سحب جثث من تحت هذه الانقاط
طبعا هذا هو التفسير العلمي الذي يعني
يؤكد هذا الكلام طبعا هذا تفسير ممكن حتى
مختصين يعني يستطيعون ان
يؤكدوا هذه المعلومات
والعمل لازال حتى هذه اللحظه في شمال غرب
سوريا مستمر حتى نستطيع
الان استاذ منير
من حيث الاولويه
نعم هلا في الحقيقه هناك بعض المدن هي
تعرضت الى يعني اضرار مضاعفه عن الاماكن
الاخرى وهذه المدن هي من يبقى التركيز
موجود فيها بشكل او باخر مثل مدينه جنديرس
مدينه حارم مدينه سلقين مدينه طبعا هي مدن
صغيره طبعا لا ترقى لان تكون مدن على
مستوى يعني كبير هي مدن صغيره ولكن هذه
المدن حاليا هي محطه تركيز الخوذه البيضاء
لسحب العالقين من تحت الانقاط طبعا
بالاضافه الى بعض البلاغات التي تاتي
لفريق الخوذه البيضاء بين الحين الحين
والاخر عن احتمال وجود يعني عالق في مكان
معين في الاماكن الاخرى التي تم فيها
العمل فالفرق فورا تتوجه الى هذا المكان
وتعاود البحث من جديد وتعاود يعني رفع
الانقاذ حتى تصل الى هذه الجثه في الغالب
تكون احيانا تكون موجوده واحيانا تكون غير
موجوده يعني تكون في اعداد مفقودين او
اصابه محوله الى مكان معين
يعني متابعه هذا الامر طيب يعني سيد منير
اليوم المعطيات اختلفت ومضى على الزلزال
سبعه ايام الان واليوم ما الذي تريده
الخوض البيضاء لكي تستمر في عملها باختلاف
الظروف التي تغيرت
في الحقيقه يعني هناك عده ثغرات يعني
تبينت وبشكل واضح ان فريق القوه البيضاء
يعني يحتاج الى الى بعض الاليات والمعدات
الاضافيه التي يجب ان تكون متوفره ضمن
مراكز البيضاء حتى يتم التعامل مع مثل
هكذا كوارث طبعا هذه الالياف بالحقيقه
يعني
لن تصل بسهوله يعني عن طريق المعابر او عن
طريق وخاصه في الوضع السوري فهو وضع يعني
معقد قليلا سيكون هناك تاخير بوصول مثل
هذه المعدات وهذه المعدات تكون ضروريه جدا
في المراحل الاولى من اي كارثه مثل هذه
الكارثه يعني 72 ساعه هي فعلا هي ساعات
ذهبيه يجب ان تتوفر هذه الاليات فحقيقه
يعني الاحتياج الحالي هي ان تكون هذه ان
تصل هذه الاليات الفريق البيضاء حتى
يستخدمها الان في سحب ما تبقى من جسر تحت
هذه الانقاض ويستخدم هذه الاليات ايضا في
فتح الطرقات وازاله هذه الانق واعاده
شريان الحياه واعاده دوره الحياه من جديد
في شمال غرب سوريا وتكون هذه الاليات ايضا
هي يعني تخص جاهزيه هذه المراكز اذا لا
قدر الله حصل اي امر طارئ لاحق ممكن ان
يتدخل فريق بامكانيات اقوى ويكون قادر على
ان يصل بسرعه اكبر ويستطيع ان ينتشر هؤلاء
العالقين بسرعه اكبر من تحت الانقاض وهم
على قيد الحياه طب هل تحتاجون اليوم في
هذه المرحله اي مساعده بشريه اضافيه الى
جانب الطلب مناشده بالحصول على معدات
واليات جديده
الحقيقه يعني نحن دخلنا اليوم في مرحله
جديده المرحله الجديده لا تحتاج يعني جهود
خلينا نقول جهود بشريه او طاقات بشريه
يعني نعم هي تحتاج الى معدات واليات يعني
قادر ان يتابع بشكل مباشر كافراد ولكن
يحتاج الى تجهيزات ومعدات حتى تساعد هذا
الفريق ان يقوم بعمليات الانتشار بشكل
بشكل اسرع يعني بمرحله الثلاث ايام الاولى
او 72 ساعه يعني كان وجود اي فريق انقاذ
ضمن شمال غرب سوريا اضافي الى فريق
البيضاء سيكون كفيل بان ينتشر او يسحب
عالقين من تحت الانقاض وهم على قيد الحياه
وهو الذي طالبنا بسرعه وصول هؤلاء الفرق
للاسف يعني يعني كان يوجد لبعض التاخير في
وصول هذه الفرق وصل يعني فريق من الاشقاء
في مصر وكان موجود معنا يمكن باليوم
الثالث وساهم في عمليات الانقاذ ولكن
لاحقا لا لا لا يكون هناك جدوى موجود فراغ
كون ان
العالقين الذين بقوا تحت الانقاضهم في
عداد الموتى ويحتاج الوقت
للتعامل مع جثه ميت تختلف قليلا عن
التعامل مع شخص على قيد الحياه الاسراع
بانقاذ شخص على قيد الحياه قد يؤدي الى
الحفاظ على حياه هذا الشخص اما الشخص
الميت يعني انتشاله وان تاخر ساعه او
ساعتين يكون يعني غير مهم هذا الامر كونه
قد فارق الحياه لكن استاذ منير الى اي حد
الاسراع في انتشال شخص عالق كان سلاح ذو
حدين يعني دائما نذكر الموتى ونذكر
الناجين ولا نتحدث عن المصابين وحجم
الاصابه يعني كيف كنتم تعملون خصوصا وان
الشخص عالق لا تعرفون ان كان يعاني من كثر
ما او من حركه ما ممكن ان تزيد طبله بعد
انتشاله
نعم في الحقيقه فريق الخوض البيضاء فريق
خضع لتدريبات السابقه لهذا الامر تدريبات
كيف ينتشر المصابين من تحت الانقاض طبعا
سنين العشره من الحرب والقصف المركز كان
على هذه المناطق كان كفيل في في عمليات
صقل مهاره هذا الفريق حتى يصل الى الى
قدره على انجاز العمل باسرع وقت ممكن
وقادر على ان يقدم المداخلات الطبيه من
تحت الانقاض يعني الكثير من الحالات يمكن
يعني تم تداول يعني بعض الصور على الشاشات
التلفزه هناك الكثير من حالات يعني تم
تقديم خدمات طبيه ومساعدات طبيه تحت
الانقراض ليس ما يتم انتشال هذه الحاله
وسحب هذا العالق من تحت الانقاذ كان طفل
الى اخره يتم فتحها ممكن وريد اعطاء بعض
السيرومات الوريديه يتم اعطاء بعض
الاكسجين لهذا لهذه الحاله طبعا الدعم
النفسي هو ايضا يعني من احد اهم اسباب
بقاء الع على قيد الحياه طبعا قد تستمر
يعني عمليه انقاذ شخص واحد الى ساعات
طويله ولكن هذا الدعم النفسي يبقى مستمر
منذ اللحظه الاولى للوصول لهذا الشخص
وخاصه اذا كان يعني يستطيع ان يتكلم او او
يستطيع ان يتواصل بشكل لفظي مع الفريق
تكون دائما هناك يعني جرعات من الدعم
النفسي لهذا الشخص حتى تزيد مقاومه جسده
يستطيع الخروج وهو يعني بامان الى خارج
هذه الانقاذ طيب استاذ منير يعني ان صح
التعبير لا تجوز المقارنه في الجانب
السوري ووضعه الان من حيث عمليات الانقاذ
وغيره وبين الجانب التركي لكن هل يمكن
القول انه في احياء في مناطق او في بنايات
معينه لم يصل اليها عناصر او اعضاء الخوض
البيضاء او الانقاذ المدني حتى اليوم
هلا في الحقيقه تم يعني الكشف على كل
المناطق التي تعرضت الى انعدامات من فريق
القوات البيضاء وتم الوصول الها طبعا هناك
اولويات كانت يعني تتخذها فريق فؤاد
البيضاء الاولويه رقم واحد هي سحب
العالقين فحقيقه كنا نصل الى بعض المناطق
العالقين وهم علاقات
ويكون هناك تاكيد ان هناك جثه موجوده فكان
لا يتم التعامل مع هذه لانها تاخذ وقت
وهذا الوقت ثمين جدا من اجل ان نحصل على
المزيد من الاحياء تحت هذه الاوقات فكان
يتم الانتقال الى مكان اخر وتتم عمليات
البحث في المكان الاخر وسحب الاحياء طبعا
المرحله اللاحقه هي مرحله سحب الجثث عندما
يتم التاكد من ان كل الابنيه المنهاره تم
الوصول الها في في يعني وتم تفتيش هذه
الاب والوصول الى كل المثلثات والحياه
التي تكون هي موجوده تحت هذه الانقاض هنا
يتم الانتقال الى اماكن تجاوز تواجد الجثث
وتتم عمليه سحب هذه الجثث من تحت الانقراض
في المرحله اللاحقه هناك اولويات دائما في
العمل الاولويه هي انقاذ الحياه ثم سحب
الجسد ثم ازاله الانقراض وفتح الطرقات
واعاده دوره الحياه شكرا جزيلا لك
منير مصطفى نائب مدير الدفاع المدني
السوريه